Este problema dice expresa el área de un rectángulo de base 4y y altura 2y
como un monomio. Aquí tenemos la figura y el área de un rectángulo está dada
multiplicando la base por la altura entonces, déjame escribir eso. El área es igual a la base por la altura, la base es 4y
4y, y la altura es 2y.
Déjame reacomodar esto utilizando la propiedad
asociativa y la propiedad conmutativa de la multiplicación, me voy a reescribir como 4 por 2
por "y" por "y" simplemente cambie el orden de los factores para juntar las "y" y los números, y ahora sí vamos a multiplicar este
4 por 2, este 4 por 2 que nos queda un 8, esto de aquí es igual a 8.
Y luego eso hay que multiplicarlo por este "y" por "y" .
Y "y" por "y" es "y" cuadrada y lo mismo que "y" a la 1 por "y" a la 1 que bueno, es "y" cuadra, "y" cuadrada.
Entonces ahí está ya tenemos el área expresada como un monomio
porque esto justo es un polinomio
de un solo término.